[Musique]
il faudrait toujours se méfier des
vieilles dames claude sarraute ne
semblait avoir de secret pour personne
fille d'un célèbre écrivain nathalie
sarraute épouse un académicien jean
françois revel et surtout trublion
médiatique claude affiche un curriculum
bien respectable et pourtant dans la
vente et oublie tout la vieille dame
confesse à son ami laurent ruquier avoir
eu une vie amoureuse bien remplie voici
donc son histoire intime le finisseur de
femme égoïste et de notre époque est
totalement d'une autre c'est à dire que
mon tempérament c'est celui d'une
dans les buts je travaillais comme me
l'a dit ma mère tepa putallaz parce que
plus tôt - toujours été entretenue armée
mari j'ai pu être courtisane j'aurais
adoré et pas faire la rue tu vois rendez
vous une clientèle très chouette libre
j'aurais adoré j'ai toujours rejeté
fallait-il donc que les petites claude
au tempérament de lolita n'est une mère
élitiste et féministe quand l'enfant
revendique un goût immodéré pour la
coquetterie et la séduction la mer
puritaine se refuse elle le port de la
jupe du maquillage et du sac à main et
il ma mère qui était tout le contraire
être monstrueux
une trouée mons deux messages à raconte
dany boon il croyait que elle pouvait
remplacer tous ses défauts le mensonge
la vanité la coquette ville par des
copies corrigées une page de livre à
toutes les épreuves
j'aurais yamoto mano je pouvais rien
défaut et mettre à nu une qualité devant
on pressait tout ça qu'est-ce que jamais
base et les remontrances de là mais n'y
feront rien pour échapper à sa famille
claude se marient vite à un journaliste
américain
mais elle ne se résout pas être la femme
d'un seul homme elle multiplie donc les
conquêtes
j'adorerais l'amour j'adore rex
c'était vraiment autant que le travail
autant que les enfants c'est génial
quelques inventions merveilleuse et puis
tu vois je suis dit quand tu aimes j'ai
un don quoi
un homme pourtant se détachera de tous
faute sa route est éblouie par
l'intelligence hors norme de
l'intellectuel jean françois revel revel
fut connu pour être le grand directeur
de l'express et le père de matthieu
ricard voit même la présente est
intellectuellement c'est elle qui m'a
donné à lire pourquoi des seeds of et je
dois dire que c'est une chose comme
personne n'avait jamais fait avant
et jamais fait depuis et à dire qu'il
s'attaquait à tous les philosophes
lévi-strauss françoise ou le tour à tout
ce qui bougeait encore ils tiraient
dessus j'ai une admiration mais total et
à la seule personne à qui j'ai écrit de
toute ma vie j'ai la seule personne à
qui j'ai écrit un mot pour le féliciter
c'était lui
claude et pousse donc seulement au bout
de quelques années la relation entre se
délite
cette fois c'est jean françois revel qui
prend un malin plaisir à les voir
ailleurs alors là il m'a foutu là lucho
dans les pattes c'était la secrétaire au
lala et de revivre encore il a voulu
divorcer après j'ai perdu 10 kilos tu
sais le permanente une bâche et très
grosse mais j'étais très minces 10 kg
par là dessus si nombre mécénat mais
encore qu'il m'a sauvé jeu c'est elle
qui m'a dit ils veulent je voyais tous
les jours à ce moment là tellement
j'étais il m'a dit que je peux au bout
de trois mois y en a marre de ne pas
plus jamais de remettre montante qu'il
laisse partir du trovan amende je pense
à ton boulot tu pensais qu'il ya main
mais je ne veux plus entendre le mot
claude refuse de divorcer une nouvelle
fois elle souhaite préserver ses enfants
et puis l'admiration est toujours là
elle se convainc plus tôt de rencontrer
un autre homme non pas vengeance mais
plutôt par sauvegarde hans un allemand
se présentent à elle
ce que l'amour on a ça me fait maigrir
de toute façon quand je dis amoureuse
malgré ça aussi il écoute j'ai une
chance pour le moment je me suis dit il
faut que tu rencontres quelqu'un fait
qu'elle soit quelqu'un qui ne vit pas à
paris il était orphelin il était
célibataire
il n'avait que moi mais métro presque
parce qu'il n'a jamais eu d'enfant et
le métier de journaliste lui donne de
bons prétextes pour s'absenter
régulièrement les week-ends et les
vacances avaient quand son amant le
reste de la semaine avec son mari claude
mènerait cette double vie pendant près
de 40 ans
un schème but en vouloir de cox un peu
quand même vers la fin parce que lui
aussi maman revel et même à la fin il
est devenu très radin mais très radin
c'est horrible a lancé la dernière chose
que je veux pour moi bon tu peux vu que
ça ne m'arrive pas que je suis encore
deux trois ans que ça me prenne cet
affreux
les deux hommes de sa vie sont morts il
ya trois ans à quelques mois
d'intervalle l'absence est à mal qu'elle
a su apprivoiser
aujourd'hui comme nous à joliment appris
qu'elle avait seulement aimé
[Musique]